No,
I think the idea of white privilege is
absolutely reprehensible and it's not
because white people aren't,
you know,
we have all sorts of privileges and most
people have privileges of all sorts and
you should be grateful for your
privileges and work to deserve them,
I would say.
But the idea that you can target an
ethnic group with a collective crime
regardless of the specific innocence or
guilt of the constituent elements of
that group,
there is absolutely nothing that's more
racist than that.
It's absolutely a boring.
I can't
thank you.
If you,
if you really want to know more about
that sort of thing,
you should read about the Kulaks in the
Soviet Union in the 19 twenties,
k,
u l a,
k s because they were.
They were farmers who were very
productive.
They were the most productive element of
the agricultural strata in,
in Russia.
And they were virtually all killed or
raped and robbed by the collectivists
who insisted that because they showed
signs of wealth,
they were criminals.
And,
and,
and Roberts.
So,
and the one of the consequences of the
prosecution of the Kulaks was the death
of 6 million Ukrainians from a famine in
the 19 thirties.
The idea of collectively held guilt at
the level of the individual as a legal
or philosophical principle is dangerous.
It's precisely this sort of danger that
people who are really looking for
trouble would push.
So and,
and just a cursory glance at 20th
century history should teach anyone who
wants to know exactly how,
how unacceptable that is.